No one has higher hopes than the studio when
it comes to a movie's franchise potential.
If they sense a feature could be the start
of something major, they might even green
light a follow-up before the film even hits
theaters.
But in some cases, those sequel plans are
embarrassingly premature.
Here are some movies that were so bad, their
sequels were actually canceled.
The Mortal Instruments: City of Bones
The successes of Twilight and The Hunger Games
made adaptations of young adult novels hot
in Hollywood.
Sony seemed poised to capitalize by bringing
Cassandra Clare's The Mortal Instruments:
City of Bones to the big screen, with plans
to follow with the second installment, City
of Ashes.
Unfortunately for the studio, the film was
a disaster with critics and audiences, earning
back just above half of its production costs.
Instead, the series was adapted to the small
screen as the TV series Shadowhunters.
Fantastic Four
Fox’s 2015 reboot of Fantastic Four may
have seemed like a good idea at the time,
especially since it boasted a quartet of critically
favored actors in Michael B. Jordan, Miles
Teller, Jamie Bell, and Kate Mara.
Critics overwhelmingly hated it, however,
and the box office results were terrible.
A sequel was slated for 2017, but it never
went into production.
John Carter
Disney's John Carter was such a box office
bomb that the film's title is now often used
as an adjective to describe a grossly underperforming
picture.
The film's critical reception was moderate
at best, but what really destroyed the would-be
franchise was how much of a loss the studio
took at the box office.
The film reportedly cost a whopping $250 million
to make, not counting its marketing expenses,
and earned just $73 million in North America.
Ouch.
Green Lantern
Although Ryan Reynolds has since proven his
worth in the superhero market by way of Deadpool,
his turn as the Green Lantern was a franchise
nonstarter and remains something of a scar
on his filmography.
Green Lantern tanked at the box office and
Green Lantern 2 lost its greenlight.
Terminator: Genisys
2015's Terminator: Genisys couldn't quite
recapture the fanfare of the original series,
even with the reappearance of Arnold Schwarzenegger
as the titular Terminator as an added boost.
The movie performed poorly with critics and
domestic audiences, which made the cancellation
of its sequel plans far from surprising.
The Cat in the Hat
Adaptations of Dr. Seuss' books have usually
done well, including How the Grinch Stole
Christmas, Horton Hears a Who!, and The Lorax.
But critics and audiences rejected the 2003
live-action take on one of Seuss' most iconic
properties, The Cat in the Hat.
The film scored just 10 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes and financially under-performed as
well.
Seuss' widow Audrey Geisel went so far as
to refuse any further live-action films.
Battlefield Earth
John Travolta's unintentionally hilarious
costume was the least of Battlefield Earth's
problems.
This infamous dud, which was supposed to be
followed up with a sequel to cover the rest
of L. Ron Hubbard's 1,000-page plus sci-fi
epic, was laughed off by reviewers and largely
ignored by audiences.
Tron Legacy
It took more than two decades for the first
sequel to 1982's Tron to come down the pike,
and it looks like it might take just as long
for the next one.
The 2010 movie's domestic box office was mostly
a bust, and despite an animated TV spinoff,
Disney abandoned plans for another movie.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
scrapped sequel you’d most love to see some
day.